you have to fail more he says you got to
step up your failure of it
all you entrepreneurs out there that
cell phone is your lifeline out of this
mess
use it if you do not change that talk in
your head you will always be the poor
person
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
99
it's evan carmichael and i make these
videos because you
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best robert kiyosaki and my
take on his top 10 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one fail
more i got a job with xerox because they
had sales training
and then for two years i was the worst
salesman they ever had
i was gonna get fired from xerox and so
i went to my rich dad and i said in
terms of why
what's wrong he says how many sales
calls you make a day i said
on a good day three he says that's why
you're not successful
same formula he says you have to fail
more
he says you got to step up your failure
rate so i found
a non-profit and at night
after working at xerox i would go to the
phone bank
up the street from where i was working
in honolulu
and i had my had a goal i had to fail 35
times at night
so i just failed 35 times now
interesting thing happened
my numbers at xerox went up you see i
was handling that fear i was i was
handling the wimp in me the coward and
most people don't want to go through the
wimp
and that's why i don't really i don't
have much time for rule number two
borrow and buy assets do you know why
they tell you to save money
i don't know
because the system of banking york
has nothing to do with communism or
capitalism
it's the banks run the world the rich
run the world
they don't care if you're communist or
capitalist
so when you save so let's say you say
one dollar u.s
one euro one yen the banking system can
lend out ten
so the entire system is called the
fractional reserve
system the fractional reserve system is
also printing money
then they tell you to save money so they
they want you to save money so they can
lend out your money 10 times
so your dollar became worthless 10 times
over
and then they used to pay you 10
interest on your money now it's at best
one percent
and they're still lending it out 10
times so that's why you don't save money
is because your money is becoming worth
less and less and less and less and less
the banks are getting richer and richer
and richer
then they tax you on that interest you
they pay you that one percent interest
if they pay you that much
japan is zero and the japanese are so
stupid they still save money
we also have zero yeah and they still
save money
how stupid is that so that's what i'll
question so how come that happens
now if i borrow money guess what do i
pay taxes on debt
i guess no why is that
i know this is this is what i'm saying
okay question
everything okay so when they lend out
money
that's how money is created money is
debt
they lend out them why is debt tax free
i don't know because that's how money is
created
and so the banks love it they love
people borrow lots of money
so how do i get rich i borrow money
and i buy assets with it the poor person
borrows money and buys liabilities like
purses
cars houses and they get poorer and
poorer and poorer
but i use debt i borrowed 300 million
after the crash
dollars in 2000 by 2010 i had borrowed
300 million dollars to buy real estate
that made me rich and the interest rates
kept coming down so my cost of money
kept coming down
and so everybody else is saying oh you
should get out of debt you know why
because they don't question the hypnosis
they're under
you've been hypnotized to work hard for
money
to save it the fractional reserve system
prints it and
then you pay taxes of taxes so i get
i have all this debt and i get rich
rule number three keep your word it's a
great time to be an entrepreneur because
if you're smart you have a good spirit
and you
you'll learn quickly so the greatest the
greatest thing about entrepreneurs how
fast can you learn
you know when you look at the seven
deadly sins
the biggest tragedy is ego said ego
or vain glory is the road straight to
hell
and so you gotta i tell you i made
mistakes i tell you i screwed it up i'm
definitely on the short list for saint
but you'd better be honest and people
trust you and they
better keep your word you know you're
only as good as your word yeah
so actions and words must be in
integrity rule number four rewire your
brain
that's why in 1997 i created the cash
flow of 96 grade the cash flow board
game
it's the only game that teaches your
accounting by having fun
so the cash flow game i i play at least
10 times
because each time you play learning
something new well what what the game is
doing because you have to move
move pieces and write and all this stuff
it's moving your neural pathways you
have to train
you know the most important thing is
change the neural pathways in your brain
and and the brain is driven driven by
your heart
and when i meet somebody with an
employee's brain
they say i want job security i want i
want a good pension
does that have medical benefits that's
their brain
it's them i can't help them they got to
rewire the brain
yeah because the economy takes place
between this year and this year
that's where the economy takes place and
in your heart and in your guts
i started playing monopoly i was nine
years old
and everybody's played monopoly except i
played in real life
you know four grand houses one red hotel
tax free
if you really if you really learn to be
rich you have to learn how to sell
how to use debt and how not to pay taxes
that's the game also if you want to have
more self confidence and self-belief
i've designed a special
free training to help you do it the
science says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action
to build a new habit and and i want that
for you i want you to build the habit
of self-belief so what i'm going to do
is email you every day for 254 days
a link to an unlisted video that will
shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below
i don't cheat on my wife i don't cheat
on my customers
i don't cheat people i don't cut corners
if i can't do something i'll tell you up
front if i screw up i'll tell you
people always kind of dump on
what you call the fast food industry
if i had to do it again i'd go work for
mcdonald's look
i have a i have an unfair advantage you
know i went to war
and at war i'm alive because other guys
died for me
rule number five transform that's why i
said when i saw that that
iphone come out i said all you
millennials all you
entrepreneurs out there that cell phone
is your lifeline out of this mess
use it so what we're doing today is
anti-fragile you know we're wartime
leaders
and we're going to come out of this
better i don't know how
but it's called metamorphosis you know
metamorphosis
is like when a butterfly i mean a
caterpillar turns into a butterfly
that's metamorphosis and the definition
of metamorphosis you can look it up the
dictionary
is the tran or the transformation from
an immature
form to an adult form
immature form to adult form in other
words
grow up so for some of us
this crisis will grow up will come of an
anti-fragile will come out stronger and
that's why i've been watching my tweets
i say you know the best teachers
are on youtube not in school because
most school teachers and this is what
jordan peterson is saying he said
jordan peterson's being attacked by his
own school teachers
because they are [ __ ] you know
they're all these guys and they tend
there they job security they need
protection
the world's a terrible place capitalists
are crooks
and all this stuff and it's a free
country you can listen to those guys if
you want
or you can listen to patrick mcdavid so
your
thing on the military leader versus the
peacetime leader
was prescient it was one of the most
important lessons
everybody should look at they have to
ask yourself today
am i going to be a military leader and
come out of this anti-fragile and
stronger
better healthier or am i going to be
crushed
by what fuller called grunch the gross
universal cashless
rule number six focus on infinite
returns
i encourage anybody listening to this or
any entrepreneur
get to the point where you don't need
money it's called the infinite return
and that's my my next book coming out
next year yeah when you get to the point
where you don't
need money you're home free
you'll never need money you don't care
you could always put a deal together
you can always create an asset out of
nothing you know it's like
i don't know what else it's the power of
god-given power so like i said when i
write a book i'm selling 50 copies
50 licenses day one and let's say i got
10
000 a license how much is that 50 times
10 000. is it 500
000. 50 times 10 000. yeah that's a
hundred thousand
yeah so i'm in i'm in the black
immediately what does it cost me maybe
ten thousand to write a book you know so
i'm in the black
the same thing if i trade a stock i buy
a stock a dollar it goes up to 10
and i sell so i have all free trading
stock i have no money and
that's what buffett's doing they're all
infinite return guys true
you have no money into the deal and you
can do it with anything
rule number seven question things today
if you know people complain i don't make
enough money in romania well you have a
cell phone you can make money all over
the world
you can't make money in dollars yen
flatnic pesos you know
it's just limited thinking if a person
doesn't change
what's inside their head the actual
thoughts running their brain
which are words they'll never change
so the change begins when you question
go to school
get a job work hard pay taxes
save money get out of debt and invest in
the stock market until you
until you question that one nothing
changes rule number eight
use tax breaks there's three kinds of
income this ordinary portfolio passive
so when you say to some poor kid go to
school get a job
they're working for ordinary income the
highest tax income in the world
i don't work ordinary income i don't
want a paycheck
passive income is generally what happens
when you invest in the stock market
i mean portfolio income so they say well
i bought
tesla at 100 it went up to 200 i sold it
so i made a hundred dollars that's
portfolio income
that's taxed at the next higher level
so when i have passive income it's tax
free
getting passive income you have to know
what you're doing so that's why i have
the best
first of all bookkeeper accounts
attorneys
bankers i operate as a team just like my
my when we flew into combat we're a team
and most people are trying to do it
self-employed way
you know i'm a good computer programmer
good
you pay the highest taxes you work the
hardest you don't get ahead that way
but that's what most people they want to
do it on their own you know if you want
it done right
do it by yourself an employee is always
saying the same words
you know this year and this year i'm
looking for a safe secure job
with uh benefits and a paycheck and uh
pension that you got that that's what
they're looking for
so if i have a job well and a
self-employed person said how are you
doing
i'm the best good i'll hire the best
but you the government's going to
penalize you for that because you're
because you're working for
a quiet blended income but it's more
passive things it's actually ordinary
income but um
you pay the highest taxes the tax law
are nothing but incentives
not punishments so if you donate if i
i just donated uh money to the food bank
because there are
a lot of food as well as 10 000 bucks
i get a tax credit i don't donate money
to
food bank no tax break so because i have
7 000
rentals apartment houses i got a tax
break you know why because i'm providing
housing
and because i have thousands of
employees the tax break the government
even sent me money to pay my employees
rule number nine consider currency what
do you recommend people do
in a market that is potentially heading
into depression should they be saving
cash
and thinking about you know becoming
more liquid like what what are some of
the things that they should do
well it depends upon the cash if you're
if you're in argentine is it right peso
yeah i wouldn't touch it i'd save gold
and silver
see what's what's his name uh what's his
head edgewater's hedgeway no
bridgewater's guy ray dalio yeah he says
it depends upon the currency you're in
sure he says so like zimbabwe
their debt is financed with external
money
japan is internally financed so that's
why the
depression doesn't hurt them as badly so
you have to learn so much about that
so i own millions and millions and
millions and millions of millions in
gold because i started buying gold in
1973 when it was illegal for americans
owned gold
and i like gold and silver because
there's no counterparty arrest there's
no
other party to it gold and silver are
god's money
so people say well it's not a good
investment i said yeah but
i i sleep at night what's that worth
you know sure so i don't care if the
dollar the dollar is corrupt the us
dollar is corrupt but
it's the strongest currency in a
horrible currency world
yeah so if you're u.s save dollars
you're in argentina don't save save gold
right i say bitcoin
you think bitcoin would be i mean i mean
bitcoin's got its problems too but
you're
so when you say save money you gotta say
what what currency yeah what
currency and rule number ten the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is understand the game the very guys
that went to the schools the best
schools
created these fake assets to make
themselves and the six major banks
richer than ever before they produced
sugar highs of
immediate profits but separated those
taking the risk
from those who would bear the
consequences so the way out of it is for
financial education
and you can do it everybody can do it
but you have to understand
the game after 1971 this is what happens
to people who save money
the purchasing power of the dollar is
going down because they're printing
money
and our school visuals these fake
teachers like and they're good people
all these financial planners still tell
you to save money well why would you
save money when these guys are printing
it
faster than you could ever ever save it
that's bad teaching bad financial advice
horrible so he says and then the second
thing they tell you to save money
and invest for the long term in the
stock market this guy is saying i said
are you nuts
this is stockman he was reagan's budget
director he's a real teacher he was
there
this is the whole stock market is rigged
for the rich
again it's a casino and a casino is
based
depends upon all these losers coming in
so those
the top can win so the losers started
coming in
right around here 1974.
it was a thing called the 401k
they needed more losers to enter the
market
and what do the financial planners tell
you save money
and invest for the long term in the
stock market they needed people to come
in here and push this up
again it's a casino like las vegas a lot
of losers
walk in winners walk out with the money
that's the game
now again was glass-steagall they
organize hedge funds
that turn owning a stock into a minute
to minute
bit rather than invest for the long term
it's a casino
we don't know when but it will come down
then all those guys those 401ks
toast that's why the rich dead company
was formed that's why i catch so much
hell
saying savers are losers you know
why invest for a long term in the stock
market when it's a casino
my concern is my the old guys like me
are sitting there with their retirement
plans which are broke
you know the california retirement
system is broke hawaii retirement system
is broke
chicago's retirement system is broke and
if and when this baby comes down
my generation is toast the way out
is for real financial education now i've
got a special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you the property
was a little condominium
one bedroom one bath
eighteen thousand dollars u.s
it was on the beach of maui
the reason the price was so low is the
market had crashed
smart investors always wait for the
crash
so this thing crashed i had to look at
100 properties once i left the class
three-day class i had to look at 100
properties in 90 days
and write a one-page report on each of
those properties
as my instructor said to me when i left
that three-day class i was 26 years old
and the instructor says your education
begins
when you leave the class
as your education will begin
when you leave this class not now
do you have a chance to talk to carlos
you have a chance to talk to
alvaro talk to them find out
learn doesn't cost you any money change
your ideas
so with this here the instructor said
i had to borrow buy the investment for
zero money okay
zero money
most people will tell you i can't invest
because i don't have money
that's a loser
please understand this this was
1974. the dollar had just gone off the
gold standard
everything was coming up fast
so i had to figure out how to buy it for
zero
and the reason i say that is most poor
people like padre pobre
always says i can't afford it
i know some of you right now saying well
i can't afford it i don't have time i
have children i have a job i have bills
to pay
and it is those excuses that keep you
poor
if you did cannot change that talk in
your head you will always be the poor
person
i just think about the economy business
okay world affairs
i i want to my job is to make
complex financial systems simple enough
so the average person can understand it
that is extremely difficult
because most people are brainwashed when
it comes to money
go to school get a job
work hard pay your taxes
save money get out of debt buy a house
and invest in a stock market everybody
who follows that program
has been brainwashed i don't even care
about money i make a lot of money
because i understand the system i would
never go to school get a job work hard
save money get out of debt buy a house
and invest in a stock market i do
everything exactly opposite
you wake up tomorrow morning let's have
some fun with us you you wake up
tomorrow morning
and you're on the street and you have
nothing
you don't have a single contact
in your network all you have
is the knowledge and experience that
you've had throughout your career
how do you build up from there well i've
been there
many times so it's no big deal you just
figure out what's needed and wanted you
go do it
you know i people always kind of dump on
what you call the fast food industry
if i had to do it again i could work for
mcdonald's
and the reason i go work for mcdonald's
you know whether it's seven bucks an
hour or fifteen i don't really care
i don't really like mcdonald's food but
they have the best business systems in
the world
you know how else can a company take
virtually non-college educated
people and build a fast food industry
across the world
and they have the best system so right
inside little mcdonald's
you can learn everything you need to
learn about business except for the
management side of it
so i just go work at mcdonald's so i can
learn even more
so i look at life as learning
i'm constantly learning you know i'm
reading constantly studying constantly
i spend my most of my time with
entrepreneurs
i don't spend my time with people who
complain about the economy you know
so nothing will really change i just go
back to being an entrepreneur
you know if you want to stay small be
the smartest guy on the block and that's
why most accountants most attorneys most
doctors never get rich
is because they're too narrow you know
they're experts in toenail removal or
something you know i mean
or my attorney a poor guy is an a
student he knows jack about outside of
that
whereas i never had i'm not i flunked
out high school twice because i can't
write
it's iron if i'm right here today but
the reason i'm pretty good
is because in the military we're taught
to be generalists not specialists
so when i sit down with my team i have
accountants i have attorneys
i have media guys i have it guys i have
graphic designers and all this so i
operate as a team
since i don't know anything so in in
actuality
being a great entrepreneur means i could
be the laziest guy
and i can know the least but i have to
have a very smart team which is the ring
finger around me
so because i was never smart i had
respect for people who are smart
and a lot of times i meet a students and
they think they're the smartest guys on
planet earth
and that lack of respect will keep them
small and that's what most corporate
guys want to do
stay small you know you got to climb
that corporate ladder you got to beat
the other guys win the job and it's all
that stuff
it's not the way an entrepreneur really
works it's it's
corporate it's school system you know
you got to beat up for the grades you
got the best grades
i don't have to be the best but i have
to hang out with the best
well the thing is you see when people
you know economies go up economies go
down
we might go into a depression worldwide
like i said
france is in very big trouble germany is
okay england's in big trouble
china's in trouble so if we go to that
we go to a worldwide depression and it
might take ten years you know
to come out of it but during these times
this is the best time i have made more
money in the last three years than ever
before in my life
you know i i bought five i bought five
golf courses last year
out of banks that's impressive yeah well
the
banks yeah donald bought ten
they're giving them away no one told me
yeah but you have to know how to operate
them you know
you have to be an entrepreneur yeah so
the banks just call you up and they say
there was this one there was five golf
courses and one hotel
in the states in arizona yeah gulf mecca
you know
and this japanese company had it and
they asked me if i wanted to buy it
about five years ago for 260 million i
said
does it make sense you know it doesn't
make sense at 260 million
so they told me i didn't know what i was
doing they said i could buy
and then last this one year ago this
summer the
citibank called up and says you want
those golf courses
and they gave me the money to buy them
one of the things i i stress here at
rich dab which i never i didn't do
for much of the time was because once
kim and i had enough money the question
is what do you do next
and if kim and i had continued to work
for money i think i would have died
so when kim retired she was 37 and i was
47.
but just as we said on this on with
vantay
it's one of your primary objectives
especially today
is when do you plan to retire because
you know the idea of having a job and
waiting for your 401k
or your stock market to save you i think
you're going to be sadly disappointed
because
what i'm forcing is a massive crash
coming that's going to wipe out a lot of
people
and i'm coming up with a new book called
who stole my pension
and all these guys who think their
pension is safe
i think wall street has other ideas on
their pension here
so when i say the young people like you
guys i said you know plan
your retirement the day you start
working
you know when do you escape from the rat
race that's the cash flow game there
i only became an entrepreneur because it
was the greatest
challenge i could take on as far as my
personal education personal development
and it wasn't to make money you know and
as i said my first business was a nylon
and velcro surfer wallet business and
the mistake i made i was successful
and we grew internationally so fast i
just couldn't finance my success
and so i started borrowing money and
which was good i started to learn how to
raise capital i learned
i learned how to negotiating you know in
the reason i was in korea
fighting taekwondo was i was out there
negotiating anyway for production
because we were manufacturing in hawaii
where the cost of manufacturing was too
too high sure so i had to fly to korea
and taiwan to negotiate manufacturing
i tell you man you're not stupid until
you're negotiating against koreans and
taiwanese man those guys had me coming
and going up one side and down the other
but that's what i did it for yeah you
know what i mean is to learn
and to learn to finance learn how to
factor you know how to
how to ship and then factor my inventory
and all this stuff
i learned so much as i was going broke
successfully going broke and so when i
explained to young people that's what i
did it for that
so that's how you get smarter but in
this academic culture you know we're
just talking about jordan peterson how
he yeah
he rails up against academics on the
academic culture the person who makes
the most mistakes is a stupid person
but an entrepreneur the person that
makes the most mistakes and learns from
them is the smarts
is the rich person so i always say to
young entrepreneurs it's not
money will never make you rich you know
it's your experience
how much you'll learn the mistakes you
make the people you make
and all those horrible experiences
they're all good experiences if you
learn from them sure and that's the
attitudinal difference of an
entrepreneur most guys are small
business guys they're not entrepreneurs
you know they open a pizza shop to make
money and they get stuck in that pizza
shop forever you know
well that's not me and the subject of
entrepreneur
is a massive subject so you got a drug
dealer
peddling drugs is also an entrepreneur
as is jeff bezos
running the biggest product pushing
country in the company in the whole
world
they're both entrepreneurs but the gap
between the drug dealer
and bezos massive so when i speak to
young people so what kind of
entrepreneur do you want to be
and if he's just here to make money
since you can do that but it's not
exciting
entrepreneurs have one thing in common
they keep going they'll change the rules
they'll reinvent them
you know they don't just take one answer
so a real entrepreneur really
makes no difference which country you're
in that's my beliefs i'm not i
i love that you know i mean it's just a
mindset
you know if you you mess with me
i'll find a way around it you know i
have a friend
he's a multi-multi-multi-family rich guy
from france
and you know france is as communistic as
it gets
75 top line for million dollar earners
yeah but that's why he lives here
yeah so
[Music]
he he started buying vineyards in napa
and sonoma
so he went back to the french government
and says
it's his wine he says i want to ship
my wine in bulk to california
and the government says you can't do
that
this is the french government's and you
can't share it and here's a guy is
i think he's five generations you know
french blind guy
this guy is this guy is an entrepreneur
entrepreneur
he says okay i can't ship him in barrels
the guy goes yeah he says okay i'll jump
in bottles so he battled all of his
stuff
it cost him more money but he still
figured out how to
creativity now he has his wine with his
california wine and all this
and so he went back to the french
government here try this
see if it's not better and so now
they're all confused because
he didn't break any rules so i'll say it
again
entrepreneur is a mindset first a skill
set
and rules and depending upon whether
you're employee or small business
the rules are different the mindsets are
different the skill sets are different
what's your philosophy when it comes to
human resources how do you get the right
people
and then how do you keep the right
people it's the most important part of
business
you know that's why i went to military
school
then i went to i was a marine corps
the reason why i talked to military
veterans you probably have the most
important skill of all
because all we're trying to do whether
you're at a general
or private you're taught to be leaders
it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is
people skills and leadership skills and
unfortunately
most people don't have it coming into so
when i do my talks to veterans and all
this stuff
i really want to encourage them you know
because they're pretty depressed because
they can't get
you know they're a walmart breeder which
is a good job
but they're afraid to take the leap into
entrepreneurship
so but military guys i don't care what
branch of service
just by the indoctrination process and
the survival rate
whether they go to combat or not is that
you learn leadership skills people
skills you've got to have that
you know whether whether you're a team
of one
you still have to deal with your
customers and the good customers bad
customers
lawsuits uh taxes government regulations
and all this
they're all people skills you know so
when somebody says to me
what do i need to learn i said boy you
better learn how to communicate pretty
quickly to people you don't like
and get them on your side you know how
to win friends and influence people
basic book the number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills
well most successful entrepreneurs have
gone blessed
right you know henry ford an old-time
entrepreneur he went bust five times
okay look at steve jobs yeah his own
board fired him
yeah you know bill gates was taken
before the supreme court
for monopolistic practices right even my
friend donald trump went down a billion
dollars
yeah i only went down a million so the
average person is so afraid of those
losses
they never get ahead because at school
they teach you if you make a mistake
or if you fail you're a failure but
that's not real life a baby learns to
walk
by standing up and falling down standing
up and falling down
and our school system punishes you for
making mistakes
that's why my poor dad and academic
was so unsuccessful he was terrified of
making mistakes well as we know there's
fewer and fewer jobs
you know american corporations say
they're hiring but they're not hiring in
america they're hiring overseas
but more than that is that the reason i
endorse network marketing
is most people are addicted to the
paycheck
and the paycheck is one of the most
sinister plots ever
pulled upon a human being if you need a
paycheck you've sold your soul
you know you sold your body your mind
your spirit
and your emotions you sit there in fear
of losing your
job or can i get a raise or you know
will i get promoted
i mean and then and then why would you
do that
and the other thing about reason we
endorse network marketing we don't think
of it as a network marketing
we think of it as entrepreneur
development because if you need a
paycheck
this is not your business you know we
build businesses
so sometimes when kim and i do a deal we
we may not receive a paycheck for five
six years you know and so these guys
come oh
am i gonna get rich quick you know and
some people do i don't know you do or
not
but that is an employee get rich loser
mindset and so the thing that network
marketing does is really kind of cure
you
of that loser paycheck get rich quick
mentality
and actually build a business you know
we
build businesses but and that's how
we're rich but we didn't get rich quick
and i don't need a paycheck i never want
a paycheck
so that's kind of a revolutionary
thought to most people up there
who went to school to get good grades
and get a job you know they get a high
paying job and then
the higher paying job you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get a
hit
that's because you went to school to get
a job and a paycheck
you've got to get away from the paycheck
and sometimes it might take two
three years to get away from that and
that's what network marketing teaches
people
it's an entrepreneur's mindset it's an
entrepreneur's spirit
not a loser employee i need a paycheck
mentality
i'm trying to explain to you when they
tell you get out of debt
that's because the money is debt
and the only way money gets out of debt
is via taxes
so all the people who work for money you
read rich dad poor dad what's lesson
number one
rich people don't work for money correct
money is
debt i use debt as money
and everybody thinks getting in debt is
bad well who told you that
i think the stock market is for losers
why would you put money in the stock
market when it's manipulated
that's what i think about so i'm always
watching the manipulation going on
behind the scenes
[Music]
that's what my brain is focusing on all
the time
and i don't pay taxes the question is
how is it i don't pay taxes i can tell
you
that's not that's an important question
because most people are so
most romanians and most people in the
united states cheat on their taxes
because they hate taxes so much but you
don't have to cheat on taxes if you
understood how money was working
you think donald trump pays taxes no
nobody has seen his tax returns yeah i
know him he's my friend
we don't pay taxes that's the question
how is it we do that
that's an intelligent question the
reason you can't ask me this question
because you don't know how i do it
that's what i'm thinking about i'm
constantly thinking about how do i make
money
how do i serve more people how do i
create new businesses
make more money and pay less taxes and
serve more people
i am very shy very very shy
you know i came back from vietnam and i
could kill people but i couldn't talk to
people
and one day i said to my when i decided
to follow my rich dad's footsteps i just
said to him
i want to be an entrepreneur he says you
got one problem i said what's that said
you're shy
i said what's wrong with being shy he
says you got to sell
you got to handle rejection number one
skill
can you handle rejection
the answer is no i couldn't handle it so
i said i still want to learn how to sell
so now this is in 1973 i was 25 years
old
and my rich dad said how's your love
life
so it sucks is he getting laid i said no
he says because you can't sell
guys got it so when i talk about
what skill do you need
when the hits the fan you better start
selling so i went to work for xerox in
1974 so i gotta learn how to sell
it took me four years and i was number
one
okay and today i'm a best-selling author
you know most
phds tell me i can't write yes i said i
can't write but i can't sell
if you can't sell you don't make money
period
end the statement you know just because
you have a product doesn't mean jack
but the important thing is you start i
don't care what product you start with
but you start and i started off with
nylon wallets
success wiped me out you know we
couldn't sell couldn't sell
also that took off then i couldn't
finance i couldn't finance couldn't find
that because the
sales kept going through the roof now
trouble is i kept borrowing and i
couldn't sustain the sales
next lesson but that's how we learn
okay you know i don't know if you saw me
on uh patrick ben david you know that
guy's a
guy is a genius member i love working
with him he's smart yeah yeah
oh is he smart he's kind of i used to
work with tony robbins and he has that
quickness of brain
yeah i'm a little hawaiian a little
slower but anyway he goes
he goes uh i told him i said you know
during the
agrarian age the church was the center
so every
small town had a church so it was very
spiritual and that was
a culture we shifted the industrial age
and then weaponry came up
so we could now kill you know that we
went from swords to guns to machine guns
to rockets to
drones you know so during the industrial
age
they started building statues to war
heroes so that was a you know
as a marine they had the marines raising
the flag on iwo jima and they have
robert e lee and grant and so everybody
everybody respected war heroes and stuff
like that
now they're tearing down robert e lee
and grant and all these guys
because america is now worshiping the
victim
finger brutality the victim mentality
that's what i said on patrick about
david
and a couple of my friends called me and
said here
and i said well you're entitled to your
opinion but i've been called better you
know
and stuff like this but i said we're
raising victims
our schools are pumping out victims and
the reason i like this guy
jordan peterson yes he says it's not
what a person
stands for you see that he did this
great thing
it's what are they against he says a lot
of times i'll stand up there say well i
stand for
socialism but they're really against the
rich
and so that's why i wouldn't talk about
andrew yang and
uh pete butterjudge and all this stuff i
wonder what they really stand for
what are they really fighting for so i'm
up front with you i'm fighting for
capitalism yeah
you know i fight for education that that
we should have better education i'm not
saying anything else inside that
i don't have a hidden agenda sure sure
so when these guys are talking about
we're going to fix the homeless i said
and what does that mean and so what uh
jordan peterson says this is they're
against the rich
they're not for the homeless they're
against the rich and that's where most
of the people on the left are and i
don't know that because i'm not
political not republican or democrat
they don't have any religious agenda you
know you're going to believe in god fine
the law believing god fine
but it's i want to know what you really
stand for
not what you pretend to be standing for
you see there's three types of ways
people work
number one is a job number two is a
career
and number three is a calling so let's
look at it this way
it's not the job you do it's your point
of view on it so a school teacher
i would say probably 30 40 percent it's
just a job
you know they're school teachers not
because they like teaching but
they like the benefits they like the pay
you know for them the paycheck is the
reward for doing something they don't
want to do
the second is a career so a school
teacher goes in that this is my career
you know someday i'll be vice principal
or you know some
superintendent things like that so
that's their career and then
we've all had teachers where their whole
life soul
is in teaching those are the best
teachers
well those are the ones i remember i
also remember the ones who were the job
guys
they were the worst some of the worst
i've ever had you know i just argued and
fought with them
they're the reason i left school so
when i talk to entrepreneurs i say is it
just a job
is it your career to be an entrepreneur
or is it your calling
and there's nothing right or wrong just
be honest with yourself
you know right now i'm going to start a
taco shop because
i need to make some money knock yourself
out you know
but when i started my first business it
was not to make money necessarily
money is important because money is fuel
for the business
but i wanted to learn to be an
entrepreneur so i started nylon velcro
wallets
i don't love the product product sucks
but i wanted to be a great entrepreneur
so i was willing to do a product that i
wasn't passionate about
but i was passionate about learning to
be an entrepreneur and then when i
became successful as an entrepreneur
i have enough money i said what do i
want to do next and i retired at 47. i
had enough money coming in
and i said well i hated school
i loved education i just hated school
i loved most of my teachers i just hated
school you know
because every time they said to me go to
school and get a job i said but i don't
want a job
i want a business you have to get a job
did i mean it was the programming i
didn't like
so with that said i became an
entrepreneur in education and today i
make
millions as a teacher but i make it as
an entrepreneur
so when people say well don't you have
enough money i said it's not about the
money
at this point because i have plenty it's
about the job you know it's what's
my calling that's what bucky fuller said
you must trust your intuition
you know and it's called your gut
feeling a lot of the times
and scientists have just recently found
out there's actually brain material
in your gut that's why you get a bad
feeling and
that's kind of where intuition comes
from it's more from your gut rather than
your brain
and my intuition kind of changed because
i went to vietnam twice i was a good
marine
marine u.s marine pilot and all this i
was doing it for god
country in america you know all this
stuff and one day i was standing on the
battlefield in 1972 and i said
what am i doing here you know why am i
killing these people
i don't hate them they don't hate me and
that's when my life
you know you start start waking up as
you grow older
so i learned to trust my intuition and
say what i had to say like
this book is about the future also
follows a futurist
so for me to write rich dad poor dad in
1997 nearly 20 years ago was about the
future
it wasn't about 1997. the question i ask
you is
are you following the herd
you know the herd generally goes off the
cliff like a bunch of lemmings
and how many are doing what your mommy
and daddy told you what to do
go to school get a job invest in a
well-diversified portfolio stocks bonds
mutual funds and etfs
is that what you're doing are you hoping
that the
next person elected whether it's
president trump or one of the other
candidates will save the economy
well we have a very important show for
people like you
because this program is about you have
to do the exact
opposite of what everybody else is doing
because if you keep doing what
everybody's doing
i'm afraid everybody's going to go off
the cliff
that cliff is not too far away right now
well you know that's why
i keep saying to the young the
millennials you know if they're a pack
of wimps
you know i meet millennials who are just
horrifyingly
weak snowflakes i call them you know
they go to college formats they're
taught
trigger events or whatever you know i
don't know what they say today but
they've got to have special rooms where
there's no
whatever i'm going holy mackerel
welcome to the real world you know and
the other millennials who are as tough
as nails i mean this is the biggest
opportunity they've ever had
huge so it just depends upon what's
between this year and this year what's
in your heart
the big question is how much is enough
you know
because i think the reason kim and i are
successful is we always started small
we actually stay small kitchen table and
we we do keep doing the same thing but
we don't ever
try to get big we we got big but i think
we caught big by staying small
we did i mean our core group is very
small yeah and then we license out
so for those of you who think you have
to start some mega company or be
you know make millions of dollars that's
not really true a big part of what makes
a company successful is whether or not
they have a brand b-r-a-n-d
almost misspelled it okay and brand
people think well it's the communication
you know but a brand is more than that
the reason rich dad is so
valuable right now is because it is an
internationally known brand the same way
as trump is known as a brand and the
real question on a brand is not just
communication
so a brand makes it easier to sell when
somebody says rich dad they go oh i
think i heard of that or
i know what the guy stands for and all
this so what a brand really is
is the entire bi triangle if you're
going to create a brand
especially in a world that's overcrowded
with advertising
communication the webs ipods print
blogs i mean there's so much competition
now for a person's time
it really is more important that you
become a brand
so there's a shortcut communication like
if i say the word ferrari
you know you get a picture of something
in your mind it's a whole body effect
but if i said hyundi or kia
you know car they're probably just as
good a car but you get a whole different
emotional effect just by the brand name
so i'm not saying hyundai's are better
or worse than a ferrari but i'll pay
more for a ferrari than i will for a
hyundai
i don't own a hyundai by the way i own a
ferrari what does it mean it's a
shortcut communication
like if i say the word apple you know
some people think of
computers and some people think of red
apple but for the guys like me who
i'm an apple fanatic you know the brand
means a lot to me i love steve jobs he's
one of the best entrepreneurs in the
world right now
and if i say the word marine corps
marine corps is a brand
it communicates everything the mission
the team
the leadership the style the message and
the marines have a saying we're only
looking for a few good
men and women that means we just don't
want to be like the army
we have to position ourselves away from
the army the air force and the coast
guard and the navy
so brands are so vitally important as a
communication tool
especially in today's over communicated
to world
there are more people competing for your
customers mind
their time you know how many blogs can
you read how many magazines can you read
how many television sets can read
how many games can you play and all this
so today if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it becomes
more and more important that you become
a brand i always say quit your job
but that's not you know i don't have a
job i've only had one job
and i never wanted a job after that
because i had to be hungry
not to say you know but we're all
different we're humans we're different
beings
if i share this diagram here you know
it's why i created my
cash flow board game because we have
four
different intelligences we have mental
intelligence we have i don't know what
that one is
spasm you probably have very good
physical to make you know
football and all that yeah emotional
intelligence but spiritual intelligence
so i went to military school in new york
the first thing is spiritual you know i
become a marine that's spiritual
yeah you know what i mean because you're
putting your life on the freaking line
yeah you know so nazim talib and i wrote
the book the black swan
he also wrote anti-fragile he says
there's three kinds of people in the
world
there's fragile and that's what our
school systems are putting out fragile
1b snowflakes and that's your choice you
want to be that way
have a good life the second type is that
sauce a fragile like a
champagne flute yep you hit it at the
shatters
then the second one is called robust and
a robust person
is like the rock you know you can pound
on them
dump on home yeah they
take it but that's all they do
they take it and then anti-fragile is
somebody
like you where they pound the crap out
of you
and you get smarter and better because
so i love nazim talent and a lot of
people call them dr doom
but the way i look at this whole thing
this economy is
we're probably going into depression you
know we're not going to get out of this
really oh yeah and so the thing is
is this good for you or bad for you i'm
looking forward to it you know the last
the last question was 2008
and i made more money in 2008 than in my
whole life
so this one here 2 000 you know what is
the 2020 i'm going to get any richer
but they're going to get poor and if
they're baby boomers they're going to
blame it on this corona virus oh my
you know that hey hit the road put on
some running shoes
change your diet get some sunlight you
know
get healthy don't get don't be a wimp
but oh no i'm so afraid of dying
you're already dead you don't even know
it yet you know
the marine corps you know in the marine
corps we used to call them corpse people
right corpse not core yeah of course no
a corpsman a corpse smells a person
who's dead but doesn't know it
wow they're so afraid of dying they're
already dead
yeah it's about taking action taking
control of your life taking control of
your health your finances everything
this is the best time to be alive right
now
i don't know what people think about
money but that's what i get a lot of is
kind of this
well you know money's not spiritual i'm
just saying it's your attitudes you know
a person's attitude towards money i make
a lot of money
but i give a lot you know what i mean it
goes to
biblical principle the more you give the
more you receive
so when i meet somebody who's not
doesn't have any money it just means
they're not giving something yeah you
know so a lot of times there's people
who would like
more but they're not giving anything so
they're like my poor
and he belonged to the labor unions and
he wanted to
work less and get paid more well that's
anti-religious to me if you want to get
paid more
work more give more that's how i see it
i'm one of those kids who doesn't like
school you know school is good
for people who like school but here is
my
poor dad head of education phd
on the governor's board of hawaii and
all this stuff and his kid me
and i'm flunking out of school because i
can't read i can't write
i said i couldn't read i couldn't write
i was bored out of my mind you know i
was just hey
so what i did instead was that's when i
met my rich dad was my best friend's
father
and he used these things called a game
see games
are the best teaching tools see when i'm
playing this game
this is how the rich taught their kids
battle strategies called chess
my rich dad taught me to be a rich man
playing monopoly we played monopoly
hour after hour after hour
you know the formula for great wealth of
monopolies four greenhouses
one red hotel so today in arizona
i own 8 000 green hotel i mean
greenhouses
and several red hotels i just play
monopoly for real
so that's the power of a game because a
game engages me
mentally physically because i actually
have to move things
emotionally because when somebody knocks
me out
i better wake up you know i made a
mistake
and spiritually because it's spirit that
wins you know if you just saw golden
state play the
play you know everybody
i mean i love lebron james i love
cleveland
you know but one guy cannot take on a
team
and i think lebron scores 60 of all the
points
in assists and all that but a better
team beat them
so when you look at business business is
the same thing
but this is a team sport i have to have
good accountants good attorneys good
marketing guys good tech
guys great staff i have to have great
leaders
you know the trouble with most
entrepreneurs are self-employed
so they quit their job and you know in
america today the sba the small business
administration says there's 28
million small business owners
28 million 24 million are classified as
non-employers
remember they're a one-man team you know
the bay like this guy said okay i'm
going to take you on
are you crazy but that's what most
entrepreneurs are trying to do
because that's what they're taught to do
in school to be the rugged individual
you know in school i was very successful
as long as i could cooperate
at test time but in school cooperation
at test time is called cheating
in the real world the guys have the
biggest team win
so all i focus on is putting the best
team together
meanwhile a lot of time the a students
in school that the doctors and lawyers
are sitting there all by themselves
they're sitting ducks
but they're entrepreneurs do not mean
that's a mindset
tactics strategy i went to military
school i'm a former marine
so i think like a military operation
which i love chess
so most most entrepreneurs you know they
have this job
okay i'm going to be an entrepreneur and
this guy says massacre
that's very good because they went to
school they'll learn to get a job and
they take tests on their own
they have to be the smartest that's like
the lebron james
i don't want to be the smartest guy in
my team but i want to have the best team
and that's why i win most of my games
that's great
i think like this and the doctors think
like this okay
yeah i got you man for some reason
i get the sense i'm gonna win i made the
my usual wise ass remark
only lazy people use their own money and
that's because
i have spent much of my life raising
capital you know today you have crowd
funding and all that stuff
but the reason i had to learn to raise
money was because i had no money
and so if you read rich dad poor dad
in there my my rich dad always said
never say i can't afford it
and was my rich dad and many of my
teachers subsequent to that
this lazy people always say i can't
afford it
i don't have the money that's why
they're poor
they have a poor mindset so instead of
figuring out
how to raise money it's just really easy
to be a loser and i call
losers if this is enough
because we all have the power if we
wanted to
to not be poor if we learned how to
raise money
what i found out the accountants and
attorneys who went to the biggest
schools are not the best
i have found what i'm looking for is
somebody who may be a private guy
who is passionate about entrepreneurship
so they're a great
attorney for entrepreneurs
you know they're not you know most
attorneys looking for the big client
like i want to work for
you know general electric what i want is
the attorney and the account who are
passionate about it being entrepreneurs
so my my guys right here in phoenix are
entrepreneurs and my
accountants are entrepreneurs every time
i hire the big name
corporate and law accounting firms i
have been
grossly overpaid and underserved
because they're so used to doing bigger
things they don't have time for a little
guy like me
it's the same with bankers i'm looking
for a banker who loves being an
entrepreneur
you know you got to have this
partnership with the bank you know i i
dump on the financial services industry
a lot
and they deserve to be dumped on but
you got to have one on your team you
know so my banker is the love of my life
because that's where i get my money from
i don't know if it's good news
except to be careful um
you know what changed my life was a book
like it did for many people it was this
book it was called the grunge of giants
and it's by dr r buckminster fuller and
grunt stands for gross
universal cash ice so when i was i think
in my 30s i went to study with fuller
you know he's most well known for the
geodesic dome and i first saw his
geodesic dome
in montreal canada expo 67 the world's
fair on the future
so my classmate from school in new york
we hitchhiked up to um
montreal just to see bucky's dome it was
a u.s pavilion and it blew me away
you know and um but we all have these
events and teachers in our lives and so
i think the good news is is
that there's a teacher like you online
now the best teachers are on youtube
not in schools anymore and um
i think that's really the good news is
what we're doing is the news
what's happening in the news today is
fake it's the old news
this um it's tragic
this corona virus you know like i don't
know if it's real i mean the virus is
real
but the media terrorism is frightening
so i've already been warned many times
to stay in my lane don't go into
medicine
don't go into this virus stay teaching
people with my little cash flow game
you know i'm talking about stay small or
will stomp on you
so i just remember back in nineteen so i
i first went to the dome
in montreal at the world's fair in 67
and i studied the fuller in 1981 and i
started in
81 82 and 83 and he was predicting the
future
he told us what was coming and
as i've said many times many people it's
not what
i want to do i don't do what i love i
ask myself what does god want done
and what god wants done is that his real
education
my opinion and his financial education
and there is no real financial education
in our school systems and that's not a
mistake
so i um that was in 81 and 83
i couldn't take it anymore i read a red
grunge of giants
and i understood it because my rich dad
kept saying
somebody's messing with us and every
time you say that you know you're a tin
hat guy your aluminum hat you're a
conspiracy or a spaceship you're an
alien guy and i'm just saying no i'm an
entrepreneur
at the time i was in rock and roll and
my first date with kim was to the police
you know and and she was out front
having a good time and i wasn't back
with the
attorneys negotiating a contract so
i'm not really a rock and roller but i'm
an entrepreneur
and at that time i said what does god
want done
not what i want to do i love rock and
roll
and what god wants done is financial
education that was my opinion but the
that's that was in 83. so yesterday
you know and so i don't know if i'm if
that's what i'm supposed to do because
you'll never know
you'll never know what god once done
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there